hello and welcome to las vegas now on
this thursday june 17th it is a great
day here at channel 8 rocky you're
hanging out outside
yes i am how's it going out there it's
going well it's it's a little hot but
it's never too hot to give back right
that's right i've noticed something
rocky
we'd have you on the roof for uh resorts
world we got you outside for something
yeah we always have you all over the
place
i know i know and of course you were at
barrett-jackson today too so you're all
over the place but having fun yeah
it was a great day and today we're
celebrating our founders day this is the
annual donation drive it's underway
as we mark our company's anniversary and
help two amazing non-profits
rocky you're outside actually at the
drop-off zone what's going on out there
yes we are out here and actually someone
just pulled up from our community tell
us your name
georgette carlson georgia carlson and
tell us why you're giving back for
with us on founders day they give us to
salvation army is wonderful you need
some help there there
if i can give it back i'll give it to
the church i'll give it to somebody
whatever i have it's not much but i'll
give what i could
oh well we appreciate that and we make
it really easy for you too you just
pulled up it's safe you get to stay in
your air conditioner car but
of course you got out of your vehicle to
help to tell our community to come on
down so thank you so much
we appreciate you and okay so let's tell
let's tell you what's going on here if
you don't know we chose two
organizations this year because last
year of course was cancelled
due to covet unfortunately but now we
are giving back to three square and the
salvation army so
we're taking your non-perishable food
items your clothing
for those in need and of course i want
to give you guys a point here make sure
you're checking the expiration dates on
those non-perishable food items as well
okay we want to give back good food to
the community
channel a team has been out here since 6
a.m greeting our viewers from our safe
drive-through
and of course you can just drop off you
pull up you just drop it right off say
hi to us i'll be out here
until about 6 p.m as well and just have
a good time it's
there's no better time to give back than
now i'll send it back to you jc
yeah i love it all the employees coming
together as well to help you out outside
if you can't make it down here to
channel 8 today
you can also donate directly to our
partner charities by scanning the qr
codes
that are on your screen right now